We're not sure what's
causing it, but we do
know that it's located
on the edge of one of the
largest volcanic
complexes in the United
States, called the Long
Valley Caldera Complex.
The Long Valley Caldera
is a 200 square mile
supervolcano that sits
under the Sierra Nevada
mountains. From the
skies all appears
peaceful. But beneath
these forested slopes lie
240mi³ of roiling 2000
degree Fahrenheit magma.
Well, I think because of
where these tree patches
are situated.
It may have something to
do with volcanic gases
that are emanating up
from the magma chamber
deep underground.
Over 700,000 years ago.
The Long Valley
supervolcano erupts with
2000 times the force of
that which destroyed
Mount Saint Helens.